yo eric what's up you know really grinds
my gears
what's that pills reasonable free
individuals
who respect each other finding common
cause and arranging a system of
governance
to bring the most good to as many as
possible
oh nothing gets my goat more than
rational discourse
yeah you know the naivety of these folks
i mean personally we gotta question
whether political philosophy
is even philosophy yeah liberalism is
more like
like uh thomas kincaid painting than
anything that resembles reality
i'm an individual in a marketplace of
ideas and i make rational decisions
based on in
value and personal preferences and
egotistical self-interest go clean your
room you [ __ ] sjw [ __ ]
anyway welcome to pale pod it's called
pillpot 30.
it's actually more like our 60th episode
total
but i'm tired of getting in my dms
almost daily
why is your podcast so lit why do you
even let these libs on
why can't you be more why can't you be
more based
also all of the people asking that have
anime abby's so
i don't know exactly it's always a good
sign yeah that is a good sign
anyway today we're going to find out why
are we so lib
do you actually get that question a lot
uh maybe once
more hamiltons and sickles one of the
things that i've realized is that
no matter how radical you think you can
go there's always layers of the onion
that go deeper
the other day i was in kind of a marxist
facebook group and somebody was talking
about how
lenin was too liberal right you know
that was the real reason the soviet
union failed right they weren't
hard and firm enough and it's like i
love that this was in
a facebook group too yeah liberal
like you always say matt or you said in
that episode you know you can always
find a more
an even more radical reading an ever
more radical reading of everything yeah
yeah
today we're not going to be following
any of the rules of formal debate
because that's no fun but
try to respond to each other's points as
best we can
in one corner representing team
liberalism is good actually
are matt and victor you know them as the
the politics guys
and in the other corner representing
team
uh libs are not based actually okay
uh is myself also acting as the referee
which is kind of illiberal but uh gonna
be a judge in your own case
that's not very liberal he's impart he's
a partial judge that's gonna be
interesting
you're gonna [ __ ] also decide who
wins this is not a liberal
democratic system and uh with me is
eric tate whose uh political views are
rather murky but
something not lib yeah i feel like you
guys are just kind of like
like you know angsty's what's the
doomers you guys are like angsty
doomers doomers i'm doomer with respect
to fantasy and facade and that's it
we're all doomed man
you're both you would do that you'd be
coming up being like we need an ever
more radical response to
the problems posed by liberalism and
capitalism
i i also think there's there's there's
kind of an aesthetic
i'm not accusing you guys specifically
but broader of like you know the libs
own the libs
that is uh there's like a kind of
i don't know seemingly subversive
aesthetic to
to being like [ __ ] the libs right now
that's popular
and for whatever reason it's associated
with uh anime
abby's on twitter i don't know why just
seems to be the case
to be fair i went through my own phase
like that i remember back when i was
like
it's 21. [ __ ] the libs phase or the
anime phase
uh [ __ ] a lip space never huge into
anime although i like some of it but
like
i ran a bit of heidegger and yeah that
was the whole thing it was just like
[ __ ] liberal society is decadent and
authentic and
nobody understands me because you know
we live in a society of one-dimensional
people [ __ ] it all
you know so i could empathize with it i
went through the phase of being like
yeah atomism is
is it's causing atomism you know reading
charles taylor and yeah
yeah there's a real problem here with
with liberalism and yeah i do think
there's some problems with it but we can
get into that in more detail
there's a lot of difficulties when you
get into this stuff because
because i mean our our real enemy a lot
of the time
is going to be capitalism neoliberalism
neoconservatism which are maybe like a
smaller part of the broader liberal
tradition so when you have
critical theorists and marxists talking
about liberalism
usually they're actually referring to
neoliberalism they're not attempting to
make
a nuanced analysis of liberalism and be
like well
political liberalism this but classical
liberalism that they're not trying to do
that they're like capitalism
neoliberalism whereas then when you read
books written by liberals
like people who are self-proclaimed
liberals they barely ever talk about
neo-liberalism that's like the thing
they have to sweep aside and be like
let's not
that doesn't define liberalism i'm not
even going to talk about it
so you end up with people just
completely talking to each other but you
know
like boats ships passing in the night my
god i feel like we're at a serious risk
of having a reasonable conversation
right now yeah
you need to be a little more angry eric
oh that was exactly the opposite of the
purpose of this episode
because everything that you said was
just so [ __ ] reasonable
well i think it's true though i mean
it's hard you've been hard pressed to
find a more over determined term
than liberalism right oh yeah totally
liberalism has meant everything for you
know
think about it it's become a basically a
pejorative in american political
discourse
uh oddly enough i've even seen classical
liberals self-identified
use it right uh as a pejorative which is
really our role well isn't that guy
dave rubin he's a classical liberal
right now
kind of reactionary augustinian oh
basically dave rubin is a little let's
just say he's a little slower than most
right so
yeah what would normally take place over
the course of a year
in a reasonably intelligent undergrad
takes him a couple decades to get to
okay so he started off as like uh i'm a
leftist and he went to like i'm
left his butt then he went a couple more
years to i'm a classical liberal because
i believe in free speech
people are too tolerant and want all
this multiculturalism [ __ ]
and then after a little while he finally
came around to realizing that
this tradition where people write books
like letter concerning toleration
and why we should you know and have all
these tracks about why we should
tolerate others sound a lot like sjws
so i'm going to become a [ __ ] weird
christian
except when it comes to certain things
that impact my personal life we're all
some of the [ __ ] that he said he
made it particularly he had no idea what
liberalism conservatism or leftism was
right since most pictures basically
consistent dick jokes
and him bitching about ben affleck right
but some of the stuff was just baffling
right like he would sit there being like
there's nothing inconsistent with uh
liberalism and having a strong sense of
community and enforcing certain moral
values
you know this is a certain kind of
freedom and it's like really like
where does john stewart mill say that
you know all right
we can choose what kind of liberties you
want people to have
if you're a consistent classical liberal
that's the whole [ __ ] point
you know you might believe something
different than me and want to live
differently than me and i'll disagree
with you but i
will die for your right to say it and do
it right ref we're rambling ref
there is nothing i would rather not talk
about any more than dave rubin and
any views that he may or may not have uh
hey i do a whole episode just on this
do we start with a assertion or a
detraction
do you think your team or our team i
mean i have some like dimensions
and concepts to talk about that
liberal views well i wanted to respond
to it to the very reasonable statements
that eric made
because like i agree with him strongly
about the way that there's conflation of
concepts and confusion over what the
actual target is and i would say that
he described pretty well like my
frustration when i see especially online
leftists
like talking about liberalism there's a
there's a tendency to conflate
uh like certain specific things like
certain forces of neoliberalism
certain really shitty things about
liberal democracy the way it is
like right now in the western world with
liberalism
writ large and like there's a slippage
there i don't like this negotiation
this discursive back and forth i want an
assertion i know that's
always the thing with these it's always
the thing with these liberals they're
always willing to compromise which is a
problem
are gonna bring us to the gulag and we
should renounce you and you should shut
the [ __ ] if they
if they found a [ __ ] oil spill in the
lake they would try to make a compromise
with it and say okay you have a right to
your own freedom in this lake
just try not to kill too many species
that sounds reasonable
[Laughter]
eric give us an attraction yeah you guys
making make some
some really really cringy like doomer
like
radical rebellious anarchist take
contra my my reasonableness earlier
which
was just a rhetorical strategy actually
to establish my authority to speak later
on and trash liberalism generally
i think liberalism is too focused on
individualism it's pluralism
is kind of a lie it's abstract
it has no bearing on how people actually
live in the real world
and they focus on negative liberty
instead of talking about like
what freedom is and how we can you know
make positive strides towards freedom
they just talk about negative liberty
freedom from constraint freedom from
state intervention freedom from it's
negative it's always negative
those are four initial statements eric
actually prepared them
[Laughter]
so response from uh the first side
okay well i think that there are two
different ways that we can conceive of
liberalism
uh one is a bad way that i reject
and the other is a good way that i would
endorse and i actually think it's
compatible with all the things
that eric is talking about okay the bad
way that we conceive of liberalism
is exactly as victor frame did uh it's
basically a philosophy that focuses on
what's sometimes called possessive
individualism
right and is usually used and appealed
to as a support for
a very exploitative system of property
arrangements
and a justification and as a
justification for high degrees of
economic inequality
and political stratification right and
we can talk all about that it's a
perfectly legitimate way to understand
liberalism and there's a lot of
literature supporting it there's a lot
of individuals in the history of liberal
thought who backed us up
and i think we should reject that for
all kinds of reasons including the ones
that eric mentioned right
the other way that we can understand
liberalism though is the way that i tend
to frame it right which is as a
fundamentally modernist project that's
focused around securing two principles
right that are inextricably intertwined
with one another right
the first is an argument that um
all human beings and i think we could
also add all sentient beings
if you really want to stretch it like
people like nospam and korsgard do right
have a morally equal status right and
because they're moral equals
that means people need to be free
because if you're a moral equal you're
not entitled to kind of impose your
vision of
good life on anyone else using various
coercive mechanisms
right and in this respect as a project
focused on securing
the moral equality of all and liberty
for all
i would actually say that most of the
progressive movements that have emerged
through the 20th century which focus on
things like emancipation
uh real material equality aren't really
anti-liberal movements if anything i
think roberto unger is right
in saying that they're actually super
liberal movements right the argument is
that we are not liberal enough
uh in trying to secure these kinds of
principles uh or
if you want to put it another way uh
liberalism isn't safe with the classical
liberals
right uh we need to be progressives in
order to really secure the project
okay and i think there are absolute ways
that you can extend this kind of
conception of liberalism
as about equality and freedom to things
like the natural world and many liberals
are doing that right
uh so for instance martha knows bomb and
coarse guard both talk a lot about
animal rights
so does peter singer right uh this
notion that well they're sentient beings
so they're moral equals
uh we can't just treat them as means to
an end because that's wrong
right uh and i think that you also see
attempts to kind of expand this vision
of war equality sometimes
uh to the notion of future generations
with all kind of associated
uh ecological implications of this right
it's not our place to use up all the
material resources on the planet
uh if that's going to damage people
living a hundred years from now or
prevent them from having a good life
but i can go on about that but as it
stands as that stands and this
conception i think that there's a lot
that's really attractive about
liberalism
yeah so the liberals are coming out with
the
typical strategy of name dropping
lulling the audience to sleep without
answering any of the
opponent's claims citing their
achievements civil rights
women's rights voting banishing the jim
crow laws all liberal achievements
and then at the end of it pretending to
take a reasonable middle ground
through two positions that they've just
laid out for us and
so we're off to a good start
you know what when i get my [ __ ]
think tank money i'm gonna
bury all of you okay well okay so like
so so to put to put it like sort of sit
like in
like sort of simply for me i think i'm
often just suspicious of people
from the left who are critical of
liberalism because i think all like just
all the things matt said i think most
people
who are left-wing agree with that um but
i think there is often a hunger for
something
uh like deeper a deeper sense of
connection to other people or like a
deeper sense of
meaning in the world and i think
leftists are often critical of
of liberalism seeming emphasis on
individualism and freedom from
something because it's like well what's
the what's the positive part that you're
supposed to have right
it's all negative as eric was saying and
i guess i think that that's a puzzle
that i'm
i i will concede i'm not i'm still not
sure
what the answer is but what i don't want
and what i kind of don't see the
alternative to
is like what is the alternative of
making sure that we treat each people as
formal equals
with like all their because if we
prescribe and i think this is sort of
the puzzle that john rawls has in
political liberalism is
you know that we do live within a
society that's going to have differences
there's going to be
pluralism of people's views and i know
eric you were saying that uh
liberalism incidents securing meaningful
pluralism and i'd be curious i wanted to
ask you what you mean by that
um because the the puzzle is how do we
live together
uh where everybody's gonna have their
own as rawls would say
our comprehensive doctrine and i guess
you know this hunger i worry when when
people appeal
you right to a hunger for something more
meaningful thicker meaning structures
something that's going to create more
community i like worry that
the other thing that's going to come
along with that is something coercive
that's going to be like yeah well you
actually have to live by this meaning
structure
so like like and i don't see how you
have both i guess is my questions like
how do you have both
the meaning structure uh that you want
and securing that pluralism and freedom
for people
so i guess i just like wanted to set up
like that's kind of how i see the puzzle
is like i think that like securing all
these things that
pretty much anyone who's reasonable and
has left-wing commitments cares about
but it's like how do you get that
meaning structure uh without also taking
away people's
like freedom seems like a real puzzle to
me
as i'm on one side of this debate and
i'm also the rap
we're not going to just accept your
premises because that's the puzzle that
you're having with this so let's go
point by point
eric you mentioned four points can we
start with your first and elaborate it a
little bit
followed by a pithy response from the
other side
not a drawn-out lesson okay fine fine
fine but
and i want to remind you eric about the
the like yeah so i'm curious what you
meant by meaningful pluralism
it's because you two don't appeal to
reason what you're appealing to
is affect and sentiment right if you're
just reasonable
and capable of understanding the other
side like we are
we'd all be better off i'm lined up i
got a couple
i got a response and then i can clarify
those points that i brought up okay
so now i'll clarify second
so my response to the things you say is
yes like lately liberalism
has you know within the last 60 years or
so
with newer people like i don't know
isaiah berlin and
rawls and nussbaum like they have been
verging towards social liberalism and
political liberalism and a more
egalitarian liberalism yes
i grant you that of course but you know
liberalism has been around for about 400
years so better late than [ __ ] never
eh
because it and and long before that
liberalism became the status quo
and so liberalism gave birth to this
status quo that's defined
by capitalism by free markets and by
self-interest and that's really the
situation that we exist in today
is all of those sorts of bonuses or
progressive moments that you mentioned
have also been held back by the liberal
status quo right we get
we get the civil rights movement but we
don't get everything we want
because the state status quo liberalism
doesn't allow it
and so yeah if okay that's great within
the last 60 or 70 years liberalism's
been opening up to more progressive
ideas
but that doesn't change the fact that
it's also given birth to this horrible
hegemony
of multinational corporate capitalism
which is also so liberalism is also the
enabling condition for that and part of
the reason i hate it
and then on to the four points which is
pluralism one at a time is one of them
yeah pluralism
whichever one you want whichever no can
i remember no responses oh
damn it whichever one single point you
want to push on eric you can choose that
one or choose another one
we'll finish one point and probably in a
full hour we'll finish one point
so pick the one that you think there's
like meat too
you can remember it and then um and then
respond later but yeah the
i mean these these four things i brought
up are kind of interconnected
because like on the one hand pluralism
is kind of the opposite of
objectivity objectivism right pluralism
means there are many
sorts of conceptions of the good and
that
the states this is maybe the classical
liberal that the state should remain
neutral towards them and not champion
any specific
notion of the good it remains neutral so
that a pluralistic society can be
you know fostered but when you talk to
economic liberals and classic liberals
and free-market liberals
they're pretty damn [ __ ] sure about
their objective facts
they don't give a [ __ ] about pluralism
relativism
identity anything like that anything
that has a whiff of
a kind of relational quality to it they
don't like it
it's objectivism from top to bottom for
them so it's
the pluralism in liberal in the liberal
tradition is still
probably a minority tradition at best
in terms of the wider liberal tradition
pluralism within liberalism broadly
okay you can admit that but within
particular points of view from within
liberalism a lot of them are not
very pluralistic at all that's the
pluralism point
could i respond to this without no i'm
just i'm i'm moderating
and i'm not taking sides at this moment
but we know what's going on i'll
remember the other ones if you want to
respond to that
the objection the initial objection to
liberalism
is that the pluralism is put on and it's
not a genuine
liberalism response yeah please from the
list they'll put it on to quell the
progressivist
liberals and then they'll go back to
state sanctioned capitalism so i
okay matt you go ahead first i want to
take on these two questions
of these two points and i guess uh in
interest of fairness and also to save
time
victor do you want to take on the other
two points that he's going to make well
i wanted to one i really wanted to
i think we just wanted to do one at a
time we might not even get done
pluralism but
i just have one quick thing there's or
is liberal pluralism put on
or is it genuine so i just want to make
one point that we shouldn't conflate
which as i said at the beginning the
shitty institutions that exist in
liberal democracies today which i think
are responsible for the status quo like
the stagnant
i agree with you eric like that like the
inability to change
a lot of it is entrenched capitalism i
actually argue in my in my essay that
i'm writing that i'm
writing for matt right now that like
that electoral politics are
the way they're designed right now
create these perverse incentives that
basically prevent change from happening
and i
but i think that that has nothing to do
with liberalism that has to do with just
electoral politics and the way that
those things are designed in our
currently existing
liberal democratic institutions so just
don't conflate that with philosophical
liberalism which is i think
the kind of liberalism that matt and i
are defending and that he outlined in
his
earlier statements matt go ahead okay
good well this is what i wanted to say
right
i think that a lot of what eric said is
absolutely right uh and
but what i think is interesting about it
is that actually you seem to accept the
broad contours of the liberal project
while at the same time denying that it
actually lives up to its kind of lofty
principles
right i mean one of the things that you
pointed out is that yeah you know it's
gradually been able to achieve
some corrosion of substantial
hierarchies over many centuries
but there are still many hierarchies
that exist in our society right now
and many kind of liberals support them
okay and we need to be emancipated from
these still
right the second thing you point out is
that yeah liberalism talks a big game
about pluralism and acceptance and
sure there are things like the civil
rights movement that we can kind of
grant it uh but at the same time it's
not particularly
accepting uh pluralism in many respects
uh and particularly
what you call economic liberals uh i
just call them right-wing liberals right
uh who aren't particularly respectful of
difference uh and i think this is where
uh again my distinction between the two
ways that we can understand liberalism
is important
because i actually see so-called
classical liberalism of the type of
spouse by
uh dave rubin once upon a time uh or
more sophisticated variants by somebody
like jordan peterson
as not really being liberalism at all
right i mean uh in the truest sense of
the word
uh what they're essentially doing is
defending a fundamentally reactionary
view of the world
using some of the language or
piggybacking on some of the language
developed by liberalism right because
what you see in this kind of reactionary
worldview is fundamentally a
hierarchical sense of humankind
right uh when you know this is probably
best expressed by people like evan burke
right where there's this idea that
the problem with old aristocracies was
they weren't mobile enough
right we had this idea that the king
should be put here and the queen should
be here and the peasants should be below
and this would sometimes lead to inept
people being in charge and who weren't
qualified to exercise
power and the nice thing that these
economic or right-wing liberals
uh see in contemporary capitalism is
that
you have a mobile hierarchy where the
people who really deserve to be at the
top
can get there because they fight for one
with between one another in the market
uh which means that the best amongst us
rise to the top accumulate the most
wealth
uh and people like bezos and so on wind
up with a lot more political power
okay uh you can see how this piggy backs
on some of the language of liberalism
when it comes to things like property
rights etc
but it's really antithetical to the
spirit of liberalism
uh as i understand it focusing on moral
equality
uh and individual liberty for all right
uh and this is why i think when push
comes to shove a lot of these right-wing
liberals
are will very quickly abandon respect
for liberal rights
if it becomes antithetical to the kind
of hierarchical worldview
uh that they really that's really what
they cherish right and probably the best
example i can think of
is somebody like ayn rand right iran
talked a big game about the importance
of
individual liberties for capitalists uh
but when the civil rights movement came
around
uh she was extremely critical of it
right uh iran you know talk a big game
about property rights but she had no
problem with europeans coming in and
wiping out the indigenous peoples
right because she's not a real liberal
right she's a believer in capitalist
hierarchies
okay and so what i would say is that
again
um the project of liberalism seen from a
properly dialectical
perspective is incomplete what we need
to do is recognize that
its progressive ethos isn't really safe
in the hands of right-wing liberals who
are never really that committed to the
liberal project anyway
it can only be secured through a
left-wing interpretation that's faithful
to the radical spirit of liberalism
at its best that's the way you're here
you're gonna have to keep your points
shorter
because uh i think the original argument
was lost
well i wanted to take a [ __ ] on rand
because i hate it
you have to be able to grant me these
things every now and then right um
eric do you want to respond to the claim
that plural
you're appealing to plurality as a good
but
denying that uh it's materially or
just because it hasn't happened yet
doesn't mean that liberalism doesn't
believe it could happen
yeah i know i mean i guess the i made
the sort of the same argument people
make about marxist right is they talk a
big game about the working class but in
the end they don't really care about the
working class
no that's not really what i wanted to
say in a way like yeah it's a
pluralistic tradition broadly
and i agree we shouldn't conflate
different
forms of liberalism with one another but
i also don't think we should hold them
so far apart that it gives the illusion
that there's no relationships
between the different strands whatsoever
like you're gonna have a hard time
convincing me that people like milton
freeman
and hayek and notzik and all those guys
are not also liberals
they're just a very different kind of
liberal yeah they took
they took the collapse of the keynesian
state and that classic liberal consensus
very seriously they wanted no state
intervention so they opened things like
the chicago school and they did they
were funded by government groups and
that turned out really well for chile in
1972 did it go look at the role of these
liberal economists who played a role in
designing
the economy that would follow the ind
government
in chile under pinochet for example that
would be
my response to that idea so yeah there's
pluralism within the tradition broadly
but then you have these individual
people that
claim to even ann rand is an objectivist
and just because somebody's a liberal
and holds a self-contradictory view
doesn't mean they're not a liberal still
all liberals are self-contradictory what
are you [ __ ] talking about
i have a different term for iran but we
can't say it in polite company
she's a see you next tuesday everybody
she's uh
she's an objectivist and that's part of
the liberal tradition even if they use
the language
it's still in there so the libs are
trying to deny other
libs from being libs because they look
bad i mean of course
no no no no i'm just kidding that was
that was made in jesus that was manages
but i think they're
really i think they're right-wing
liberals who are
apathetic at best and weary uh at worst
of the most radical dimensions of the
liberal project right
and you saw this from the very beginning
people like burke uh are willing to
grant a few things to liberalism here
and there
in order to piggyback on some of its
rhetoric to defend things like property
rights okay uh but they're not
wholesale committed to the project in
the way that somebody like say john
stuart mill
uh would be committed to it let alone
something like rawls or nurse bomber
uh even i would say karl marx you know
what i mean and a certain respect we can
get into that later if you want
well my other points are a little more
abstract if we're going to have a proper
debate here you have to actually answer
what the other person says instead of
saying
something about hayek and how hayek is
or is not a liberal
i don't think that's up for us to
ascertain when we're trying to deal with
the others argument so so do we want to
deal with pluralism still
does anyone have like an extended point
to make about whether or not
liberalism is truly pluralistic or
uh yes it displays a facade of plural i
can say that liberalism philosophical
liberalism is the only truly pluralistic
political philosophy i mean like
like these other ones i mean
i don't i don't i can't think of an
alternative that is that like that
that is so central to its its
philosophical underpinnings
committed to pluralism than liberalism i
mean it's
the only option yeah i mean i i would
say actually uh just repeating my
earlier point that
i agree that there are a lot of
constraints on individual and social
liberty
uh in liberal societies to this point
right uh and that we're still not
inclusive enough of real difference
right uh like the difference between uh
human beings and animals for instance
that's still really
stressed uh by some level thinkers or
the difference between
and i think this is a really radical
form of difference you know present and
future generations right
uh where i what i just think is that
it's not impossible in fact i think it's
quite likely that these groups are
inevitably going to be included within
the liberal moral universe and indeed
they are increasingly being included in
the liberal mourning universe
and where i would defend liberalism is
by saying uh it's in victor's line
the only doctrine i can think of uh that
had the capacity to gradually start
including these uh kind of figures in
its moral universe
in a truly inclusive way uh most other
doctrines that you can see certainly in
european thought
uh have been rigidly hierarchical
focused on stratification uh and denied
dignity
uh to many human beings let alone
uh non-human animals all right i object
pills acknowledges pills right to object
thank you pills
okay so you're saying it's
non-hierarchical
but the basis of liberal the liberal
individual
and yes it's taken a long time for the
savages then women then
potentially animals if you're gonna take
liberalism that far i would i have
very rarely seen it go that far but the
definition
of something that is worthy of having
rights
must be rational and must be free
and that ensconces a hierarchy from the
very start
that yeah you could say that it's
progressed by
saying eventually okay women are
irrational or capable of being rational
but it does ensconce the hierarchy
specifically and still
with respect to nature by admitting only
rights
to rational free and particularly
individual agents as if that's what a
human being at base is
well i would say it doesn't have to be
located just in rational beings
and i think just to eric's point you
know you already started to see the
shift occurring not recently but
actually in the 18th century in the work
of people like jeremy bentham right
uh people often make fun of bentham and
there's a ton of stuff you can make fun
of them for
but they forget that he was an early
pioneer for animal rights women's rights
uh you name it uh and one of the reasons
for this is you said look you know we
have to
drop a lot of the speciesist uh
prejudice against non-human animals
uh and recognize that if they are
sapient beings that feel pleasure or
pain
they fall within our moral universe
right uh and a lot of people push back
on him for that and you know we can have
a debate about it if you want
but what i think you're seeing now is
really the recognition that there was
something
really to this argument and it's
gradually making more of a headway
um in liberal democratic societies right
so i wouldn't say it's even really all
that novel i think it has deep roots it
flows pretty consistently from
uh liberal arguments about the moral
equality of all sentient beings
uh and again i think that that's
but i should be carried out and
radicalize even further i do want to i
do want to touch on pills's
point about individualism though i mean
i think that that's i think that's
starting with the individual like
i mean first of all your description of
it i don't think is exact that's an
oversimplification of where like current
like you know philosophical liberalism
is
is situated like you know i i don't
think that it's merely a rational
individual
but i think it has to start with the
individual um i mean
and and maybe this is just in my mind
because lately to my students i've been
teaching hegel
and uh you know for hegel there's like
the starting with the individual but
it's a dialectical process where you
realize
like that you can only realize your own
individuality and freedom through others
and i think like liberalism still starts
with the individual
um but you know current current trends
and and
versions of um philosophical liberalism
definitely
don't only rely on this kind of naive
appeal to
um absolute rational individual and i
guess i mean
you know if the objection is an emphasis
on the individual
then i guess i'm kind of curious like
what's an alternative starting point you
know
yes i will expand on that because we are
going towards
matt brought up animal rights
so we got to talk about what it means to
have a rights
based approach which i hope to reveal is
a
dog [ __ ] based approach and
individualism and how what different
ways we can conceive of individualism
even the most
communitarian collectivist marxist
critics
do believe in an individual but they
believe in it in a different way
then the classical liberal tradition has
bequeathed us
okay like i said i i'm still gonna argue
that some of the more
progressive aspects of liberalism have
really emerged since the 1960s
and are not part of the longer tradition
so
individualism is normally considered you
you look at an individual as a
pre-formed
entity who is fixed who enters into a
social world right
and that's the part that is wrong the
part that is right in my opinion
is what you were saying about hegel that
in a way
we are pre-individuals and we negotiate
our individuality through our
relationships with others
through our relationships with things
through the contexts we're born into and
the cultural values that we pick up in
a way that you cannot abstract the
individual
from that context and this is what i
meant when it's too abstract
it abstracts classical liberalism
abstracts the individual
from context and looks at it as a
self-contained entity
and then that self-contained entity can
now be assigned
rights and those rights are valid no
matter when
and where you are because it has to be
now universal
and then and and then negative liberty
is built into that right so
when the individual is born and enters
into a society we must do our
best not to constrain their freedom not
to put up external impediments to their
freedom
rather than thinking of government
intervention
regulations rules as things that
scaffold us towards a more full
self-realization
of ourselves the classical liberal wants
to say that all of these external
impediments are
actually inhibiting our ability to
express ourselves
and i think that is patently false
because the individual is not an
abstract entity
that is born into a context it's the
context
that determines what the individual's
aspirations beliefs
and again like i know that the more
modern liberal critics have moved on
this
but i'm gonna say for the last three 400
years that was the standard view
and then after the pragmatist started
harping on
saying we need to be more pluralistic we
need to be less
reifying when it comes to the individual
we can't be
atta atomistic how do you say atomistic
individualists
as if individuals or the atoms and
society is just a sort of
epi phenomenon based on the collection
of everybody's daily actions that's
that's
the wrong way to look at it that's the
point about individualism
i agree with that right then just this
is point of order i'm not making a point
oh wait i'm making a point of order not
a point for my team
um so we're gonna focus then because you
as victor said and as eric just said
we've moved on from the definition of
rights as being given to only
rational that means the something that
knows what is good for them
and we you seem to both agree victor and
the positive and eric in the negative
that the issue of freedom and where
freedom comes from
is the individual the locus of freedom
becomes the point of contention here
so uh if matt you're gonna make the next
point what do you
say about the contention that the
individual is not
actually free and that that part is the
abstraction that's been
bestowed on it from a theoretical heaven
yeah i know i completely agree with
eric's characterization of the classical
liberal tradition
right uh i think that it's very true
that if you read anybody like locke
or kant to a lesser extent can't you get
this sense that
the individual as this kind of
atomically fixed point
is at the basis of everything that's of
value and
one of the biggest problems uh with this
point of view is of course that it's
alienating
and it is highly abstract right and i
can't really add anything to that
because i completely agree
but i what i would say is that i don't
think that that
is a point against liberalism uh
as a broader historical movement i would
say it's a point against
a historically circumstanced conception
uh
of what liberalism is about uh that i've
all we've all seemed to have
acknowledged we've moved on from right
uh and i agree with victor that i think
hagel was a great innovator here
right uh because hegel in many ways
takes up the liberal project that's by
saying yes you know what we need to do
is talk about
freedom and emancipation as being
central
uh to the human quest right and i think
he actually innovates a lot on this by
making more clear how this is connected
to a certain kind of egalitarianism
by saying wow but you also need to
recognize that freedom can't just come
from you
it's also dependent upon other people
right and marx will radicalize this
further by saying
uh your free development is dependent
upon the free development of all
right but where you know i push back on
the idea that this is somehow
anti-liberal is that
the moral impetus behind the sigeleon
project
and this marxist project are is the same
right uh securing freedom for everybody
uh trying to make sure that they can do
so now in a communal context
and where i think people like hegel and
mark's really
innovate uh and provide a lot of
important theoretical resources for the
liberal tradition
is by focusing our attention on the
importance of
what's sometimes called social freedom
right uh the fact that you can't just be
free
if you're at this liberal atomic point
pursuing your desires in a market
society
uh you can also uh certain kind of
resources and capabilities in order to
lead a
rich and flourishing life and i think
most importantly you need to be able to
have a substantial say
uh in the institutions that govern you
right yeah
i agree with your points and what you're
saying about hegel and marx
but then you have to turn and look at
the sort of
academic liberal giants out there like
ronald [ __ ]
who calls someone like marx an illiberal
which
to me is incomprehensible marx is all
about democracy
right he's trying to get there for us
he's just getting there by
through a deep analysis of capitalism
three volumes
but calling mark's an illiberal which
liberals
do on the reg as far as i can tell seems
a complete misrepresentation and it
comes from a place
that values i think the individual
as this atomic unit as this abstract
entity
that then provides the basis for a
rights-based approach
and then the right space approach
forgets about the duty we have towards
other people that's the other problem
we have rights what do i get what do i
get
but we don't think about how those
rights are
actually in relation to duties that we
have i have a right to use the resources
around us
but i don't think i have a duty to
replenish those resources and make sure
that future generations aren't living in
some kind of
ten percent world where there's species
collapse climate change and all these
other problems that we're dealing with
today
clearly if people thought like you guys
are saying liberals think like
50 years ago then we wouldn't be in this
[ __ ] situation with things like that
i know it's kind of like a trump card to
play climate change
but still i mean like it's we're also i
think it's a valid point
even if you take the climate first of
all the question
is if eric if what's eric saying is true
that means that you
you aren't actually liberals so can we
answer
a more progressive edgy band of liberals
for sure but i don't consider you guys
the norm
in terms of the way common sense kind of
liberalism tends to work and even again
some of these big
intellectual academics who the way they
portray liberalism doesn't that was why
my
team can you can you first answer that
are you
are you libs despite the fact that other
libs hate
marx yes and then b can you argue
against his point that was buried in
there which is actually the central crux
of this disagreement
the rights based approach to politics
yeah
i'll i'll let vic to go first and then
i'll go yeah you
maybe i'll leave the the right space
defense more to you but i i just want to
say like this is the problem i'm having
i'm feeling like a little bit dizzy
because
there's a lot of conflation of like okay
what is like currently existing people
who call themselves liberals who are
common sense like there's a shitty
common sense that exists in our world no
one here would disagree with that
like people out there regular like you
know living their lives have a really
stupid common sense like people who work
in business but like is that liberalism
i feel like you can't
conflate and be like just because
there's like shitty wall street people
who are like looking up for themselves
he named an epic academic in his defense
okay i mean at the end but like i don't
know i don't know like that many
academic liberals who i mean i've met
fascists who call themselves
classical liberals right yeah and i
would also say that you know there's not
there's not you know just because
there's a lot of people who misread marx
like i actually think
the the really the to me like the
central issue is that like
the moral kernel of liberalism as
like like a quest for freedom
emancipating ourselves from kind of like
arbitrary traditions right like
the movement of history is about like
moving humanity
beyond things that we discover through
investigation through the enlightenment
uh rationalism
that were arbitrary things that were
being imposed on us to live a certain
way
liberalism is part of the broader
project to move beyond that to find the
conditions for a better human life
and ultimately that to me is what
liberalism is that's the project of
liberalism i think
you know all these kind of like you know
dumer like online leftists who think
that they're going beyond liberalism
they're liberals they just don't know it
like like they are committed to that
same moral project
and they just don't know it and that is
ultimately what i'm defending here
i do always think it's funny when people
say i'm a lib i hate liberalism because
i want to be free
right i'm like wow you know yeah that's
why that's why when you read the
literature it's
you're either a liberal or you're
critical of liberalism you're not like
something else but most of people who
are critical of liberalism on the left
they're critical on
based on a certain kind of moral
commitment which i argue they don't even
know is liberal
but anyway matt do you want to address
the right space part you do though
victor
have a very liberal interpretation of
liberal
yeah and of not of critical liberals you
can't really just like
draw a circle around people who are
critical of liberal and say well they're
just
moral grandstands
actually maybe they have a philosophical
point to make like hey the individual is
actually formed and not fixed
it's a process and not a predetermined
condition
that's not what intrinsic to the liberal
project what i described earlier is this
historical project
of like trying to free human humanity
from arbitrary rule
that is to me the intrinsic aspect of
liberalism and that you know that is not
that does not commit itself to some you
know
atomistic um like sort of ontology of
the human being like that like that's
that's
that was one way i think at the time i
mean hegel i think is really useful here
with like the dialectical project of the
movement of history of thought it's like
that was a move that needed to be made
made to free humanity from this idea
that they're like
part of some arbitrary community
hierarchical community where they're
like under
their surfs in this like set order and
they're all one holistic unit
and somebody needs to come along and be
like no we're actually individuals
and like [ __ ] you like that's like a
necessary step in the dialectical
project towards freedom
yeah we're not just extensions of our
sovereign leaders
exactly exactly that was just a
necessary step but like that's not
intrinsic to like the
the moral intuition that liberalism is
based on
which is you know i think freeing
ourselves from arbitrary
like rules matt well i thought all right
yeah no i was going to say that um i
think you know first off i'd like to say
that i'm a liberal socialist
right same uh or rawlsian liberal
democratic socialist if you want the
really long term
uh so i'm just as critical of classical
liberalism in some sense
as you would be in some ways i'm more
critical of it precisely because i think
it's a bastardization
of a lot of the principles that i hold
through right uh it's kind of like you
know i would never be part of any kind
of club that would have them as a member
right no true scotsman there you go um
but you know
on the question of um you know
is liberalism compatible with this kind
of more robust
holistic non-atomistic conception of the
human being
uh i think it absolutely is compatible
with that uh and again i think that you
can see starting the 18th century
um culminating with higgle but there are
certainly precedents
there's a recognition of this on the
part of major figures in the tradition
right
uh bentham is one example uh and
people pointed out that there's a
certain individualism to utilitarianism
but it's also a very egalitarian
doctrine right in the sense that you're
not supposed to feel that your own
happiness
over the happiness of other beings other
sentient beings
right and this can have very radical
implications in some ways if you think
about
the dangers of things like speciesism or
whatever it happens to be
right and then you know starting in the
19th century you start to see people
become
very concerned with things like future
generations which eric brought up right
because you'll start to see people
asking the question well is it really
okay for me
to be so concerned with my own happiness
that
i ignore the problems that i'm passing
on to people who'll be living 100 150
years from now
right and i also want to point out that
i think that this is a real
accomplishment in some sense
historically
right uh because if you think about you
know the way human beings typically are
where we're monomaniacally determined by
ideology
uh we tend to think in highly
self-interested terms as the kind of
caricature of liberalism itself
kind of uh points out right uh getting
people to think uh
in this impartial way about the moral
equality and the equal worth of all
people
is quite an accomplishment right uh and
i also want to say that i think
liberalism's critics have understood
this sometimes better than people on the
left
right as uh victor was pointing out uh
because if you think about somebody like
nietzsche and heidegger right one of the
things that they consistently point out
is that
they see a strong elective affinity
between things like uh socialism and
liberalism
uh since you know in nietzsche's case he
sees them as both fundamentally
christian projects
focused on achieving a certain kind of
universal
human brotherhood or fraternity right uh
and in heider's case in the introduction
of metaphysics he says they're both
like liberalism and socialism are both
metaphysically the same
right and they're complicated reasons
for this that we can get into
uh but i think that we should actually
take the critics seriously on this if
nothing else
by recognizing that they're detecting
something that a lot of progressives
don't which is that
there's a strong affinity between these
two doctrines
because liberalism is fundamentally a
progressive idea
uh it's just not safe for the classical
liberals which is why we need to boot
them out of the liberal camp
get them alongside the conservatives
where they belong uh and take
possessions
of our tradition and it's radical core
get them to see what dave rubin saw
yeah exactly push them in the reuben s
direction if we could all be more like
reuben i think the world would be a much
better place
personally yeah i i agree
i agree with you why don't we get to the
actual distinction because we're
brushing skirting around it the actual
distinction between
uh possibly what you're calling liberal
if it includes hegelian freedom
uh versus marxist the marxist take which
would be
which subject is it that you are
universalizing
and that fundamentally for in the
distinction between the two has to do
with class
are you universalizing
sort of a bourgeoisie middle class
person
who tends to be like us having time to
read and write and
learn what freedom is learn learn the
definitions of freedom
and rationality learn about rights or
is the individual that is universalized
necessarily a member of a class
specifically the proletariat that is
responsible for
uh power in a society and the way that
society moves
and they're exploited but they're too
they're too ignorant to know that they
are
and just a point the reason that marxism
has
been very contested and very
controversial over the 20th century
is because liberal individualism has had
an uneasy relationship
with the marxist kind of idea of
collectivism
and the idea that we're part of a group
right because when
like liberalism really comes into its
own and you determine what kind of
liberal you are
when you can articulate what you think
the ultimate
locus of value is whether it's the
individual or whether it's the group
and i think for a long time liberals
have chosen the individual and marxists
have chosen the group
and that's content that's continued
today in identity politics and
and more relational thinking about
identity that it's the groups and the
collectives
that's the ultimate value of loca the
ultimate locus of value
and then the other thing is the proper
relationship of the state to the market
so the more conservative you tends to
have a more minimalist government
and more power to the market whereas
maybe
newer strains in liberalism and marxism
all along has always
said like the state needs to have the
ultimate
place in relationship to the market
introduce rules and regulations and
things like that to help people have
better lives
so i think i think those two points the
group and the individual
and the relationship of the state to the
market has always been
kinds of cruxes just adding to what
pills is saying well let's focus
let's try to focus make it clear which
subject is being universalized is it the
subject of a class
or is it the free individual autonomous
yes
same sort of thing i think so i just
wanna i wanna start i'm gonna answer
that specifically but i also wanna start
you know because pills in one in your
marks video i think you very correctly
and usefully
emphasized several times that the marx
theory
that people are mistaken if they think
that marx has like a moral theory like
he's not a normative theorist he was
like a he's like a
almost offering a a description and an
explanation of what's going to happen
because of the forces and the tensions
that exist that are inherent in the
system
so i think people today will be like oh
like marx's moral evaluation
is you know the collective but i don't
think that marx had
uh you know a moral theory but i think
liberalism that's a difference
liberalism very much
is a standard for moral judgment as
valuing the individual
and i will say you know to answer the
question directly
i do think that um you know judging
things based on
like the moral core being the individual
it
you know i don't love it to some extent
but i but i think that you know judging
things on the collective seem much more
problematic to me because where do you
measure the collective
like what what gives a collective its
essence where does one collective start
another one end it's just like the the
for me the individual is just a much
more
uh useful starting point that's not to
say you can't you don't bring in like a
hegelian dialectical approach where you
you show how the individual is only
possible as developing within a context
but it's but it's the starting point so
this is the razor's edge where you get
to and then this is where you decide
i victor i'm a liberal because i fall on
this side of the razor
that is one of the reasons there are
many other reasons i think but that but
that is ultimately the reason that you
have to start with the individual
and also i think the the like
the drawing of lines so another place
where i distinguish myself from maybe
more modern leftist theorists
on like the question of the collective
of collective self rule
is that i do think that institutions
which is has always been a part of
liberalism like institutions of rights
going back to the previous topic
are uh necessary and also i would say
consistent to some extent with
uh with the hegelian dialectic right
because for hegel each step
right in in the philosophy of right it's
each step
is further making our freedom objective
by putting it into something that we can
that is objective in some ways
the way i was explaining to my students
at least is i think that what
institutions are doing and what the
dialectic in general is doing is
making something more objective but also
making it more reliable right so we make
our freedom more reliable by moving to
the next step because
and i think institutions like laws and
rights formal rights
make our freedom uh more objective
and more reliable in a to a certain
extent it almost creates a space
for our freedom to be expressed and and
it's a space for our recognition
uh with other beings that is expressed
through that freedom that is secured
through institutions
and i think liberalism has it for a long
time in the tradition been
associated with that and i think that's
in contrast i want to emphasize
to some um contemporary more left-wing
radical theorists who want to get rid of
institutions right kind of the
anti-institutional collective
theorists um you know i have in mind
like the radical democratic theory
the uh theory tradition some people in
the in the tradition of participatory
democracy um
but yeah yeah i wanted to say something
about the
way that we approach groups from a
liberal perspective uh because i think
there's two
different ways that we can look at this
right uh one is that
i think that groups are important from a
moral standpoint uh to use victor's uh
you know language uh but it's they're
important from a moral standpoint
because they're important to individuals
right uh if individuals who are actually
existent right now
don't choose to value groups or
associate with groups and particularly
if they're coerced into groups
that they don't have any kind of
normative worth right but if
individuals do choose to enter into
groups uh and to form communal forms of
self-organization
uh then that's something that's valuable
and it's something that a liberal a good
liberal society
including a liberal social socialist
society has every reason to cherish and
try to preserve
right so i don't think that there's a
problem with that right i think that
what marx was critical of
uh actually was the way that certain
people can be interpolated to use the
alpha-zarian term
into groups uh through a process of what
the frankfurt school called real
abstraction
right and the interesting thing about
real abstraction of course is that
you're interpolated into a kind of
identity uh
that isn't real in a material sense
but it has real consequences because of
course structures of oppression treat
you as if you're a part of this group
and if it is real and as if it is real
right uh and in these kind of
circumstances i actually say that
we should regret reject uh this process
of interpolation
and try to emancipate ourselves uh from
these kind of
false identities uh that are often just
put in place
uh of real um
pro like projects that are aimed at real
emancipation right uh and i wanna
include a lot of the ways reactionaries
think about groups
uh for instance in terms of national or
ethnic identity or in terms of
patriarchy
uh into this category right uh of real
abstractions that are used to justify
systems of oppression
right uh and now on the question of you
know how marx would approach groups and
whether he's a collectivist or an
individualist
i think that ultimately marx is an
individualist right
it is more humanist phase if you want to
call call it the moral core of marxism
and i understand for victor's reasons
that it's also troublesome
he makes it pretty clear that what he's
really concerned about is human freedom
right uh not equality between groups and
certainly not equality between
the ruling class and the working class
you know through their liquidation
it's just that he says that if you
really want to achieve emancipation for
individuals
it needs to be in non-alienating
conditions
right where again the free development
of each uh becomes dependent or is
recognized as dependent upon the free
development of all
okay and what i think is problematic
about a lot of the 20th century marxist
movements
is they lost track of this kind of
humanist insight
that's at the moral epicenter of marxism
and i think this speaks to victor's
point as well because
what you saw people becoming concerned
with is just what i see online uh
now just concerned with smashing as i
sometimes see it right
uh that the goal of being a good marxist
is to smash the system right
uh or smash capitalism or smash you know
the bourgeoisie or whatever
and what i always say is no you know the
point of being a marxist isn't to smash
right uh the point of being a marxist to
try to get a better society to emerge
after we radically transform this one
right uh and if you don't keep that in
mind constantly
you're going to lose sight of what we're
doing this all for
right because if our only objective is
to smash for smashing stakes
then there's really no reason why we
should get behind such a project
well hayek is far more i want to defend
this poisoning the well that's happening
here because hayek is far more liberal
than twitter people are marxists
but you answer the question you answer
the question that you asked yourself
which i think is totally the wrong
question is marx an individualist or a
collectivist
he's an individualist not at all the
unit the individual is universalized
by being a member of a class you can't
say it's an either or
and i totally disagree that marx is a
liberal uh based on that definition i
would say he's a liberal i think
in the hungarian sense he's kind of a
super liberal right he recognizes that
there are
fundamental limitations uh to the
potential for human emancipation in the
capitalist society
uh it's the best what we've done so far
and
classical liberalism is consequently the
most emancipatory ideology that's
existent
up to this time but we can do a lot
better which is why
uh we ultimately need to see the society
superseded and replaced by something
that's
considerably more equal and considerably
more uh free
but not just as individual as opposed to
collective because that would be wrong
to say about even though
i have like the point about this the
whole
it's wrong-headed to oppose the
individual to the collective in the
first place
yeah because one this goes back to my
point again that i was saying earlier
you were always
already part of a group before you
become an individual
right so there's no sense in opposing
them and abstracting some kind of
individuality
out of the situation it's always in
motion
and in development it's not you're not
an individual first and you get to
choose what part of
which group you join ask any feminist or
any person of color about this
and they will say yeah of course i'd
love to be an individual but the problem
is everybody [ __ ] else
telling me that i'm part of this group
i'm part of that group i have these
characteristics i have those
characteristics
you're always part of a group first and
then you get to become an individual if
you're lucky
even and then the other point is that
yes marx is not an
individualist i use this quote lately
only in
community with others has each
individual the means of cultivating his
gifts in
all directions only in the community
therefore is personal freedom possible
no marx is not an individualist and that
quote from the german ideology
would probably back up my point and the
third thing is you're bringing up the
idea
that yeah okay marx is a liberal but a
big thing that's always distinguished
the liberal tradition from the marxist
tradition is the liberals take a
reformist
approach a gradualist approach we can't
change things too quickly we can't
radically de-territorialize
we will go nuts whereas the
revolutionary approach they waged
they waged two revolutions to radically
change society
three revolutions if you had the haitian
revolution right okay good point yeah
french revolution
yeah but i mean did that that that
energy kind of wavered
once the sort of bourgeois class
develops
and the status quo developed and that
revolutionary energy got
really put aside until marx
and marxism sort of revive the idea that
perhaps we need a revolution
and other liberals saying well maybe
reformist
gradualist approach is better and that's
cl that's historically been one of the
main
turning points between marxism
liberalism revolutionary
reformist okay these are my three
responses
there's two things that i want to say in
response to that right uh one is i agree
with you that marx is not a
methodological individualist in the
sense they say kant is right
i do think he is a humanist concerned
with individual emancipation but again
uh he sees that and he understands that
it can only be achieved
uh if you aren't just concerned with
your personal emancipation but the
emancipation of everyone in society
right
uh on the more important point i think
about uh the relationship between
marxism and groups i think that you're
absolutely right and i think that this
idea of real abstraction
captures it nicely right uh women are
a kind of real abstraction as a group uh
because we live in a patriarchal society
where being a woman typically means that
you're designated to be inferior right
uh
and until we eliminate the kind of
patriarchal strictures that are
associated with this
it'll be very difficult for many women
to achieve a kind of individuality
because they're denying the
opportunities at self and individual
expression
uh and to form neuron coercive forms of
social organization
um through patriarchal mechanisms right
uh so i think that there's every reason
to kind of look at things in these group
ways
uh when it comes to criticizing
interpolation into real abstractions for
the purposes of domination
right the one thing that i want to be
critical of though and i want to be
really critical of this point
uh is it if you start to say things like
this the group pre-exists the individual
this can very quickly start to take on
extremely conservative connotations
right because this is exactly the
argument that burke makes
right uh burke goes up to the french
revolutionary so i presume you like
since you're fighting
can you please not say that the group
pre-existing the
that's not a conservative argument at
all that's just like
you can also make it a linguistic
argument you can make it okay
it's an argument identity politics
this is exactly what he makes right this
is getting started argument against the
french revolutionaries is
society pre-existed you there is a
social contract but it's a social
contract between those who came before
you and the dead so how dare you have
the gall
to think that you can just unilaterally
decide to break this contract
and engage in revolutionary agitation
right the group in society pre-existed
you
they wanted things to be this way they
built them to be in this fashion
and it's not for you to decide to shift
things unless you do so in a very
gradual fashion
right and this is why i'm really
resistant to the argument that
the group pre-exists the individual and
we should be granting this a certain
kind of moral status
uh because that can very quickly be
turned as a justification for
all kinds of conservative traditions
right uh and you can think about it i
hate so much
when debate lords use logical fallacies
but this is
just the worst example of a slippery
slope that i've heard today
no i mean i don't think it's a slippery
slope at all i mean look if you appeal
to a group
then you're going to be a conservative
no no that's right i don't think so
to be fair you are implying that my
argument was that the group
precedes the individual and that was not
my argument at all
i know i i'm saying that i think i think
that you should be very careful about
employing that kind of rhetoric though
and i mean if you think about it
there are all kinds of conservative ways
that you can cash this out this
communitarian conception
right uh that the group has a kind of
ontological priority
uh over the individual or formative
status that pre-exists the individual
right a lot of the arguments for
criminalizing homosexuality in the 1950s
were based on precisely this kind of
concept right that
uh you privately might want to live out
uh your perverse sexuality
right uh but we as a society have always
felt that you shouldn't be allowed to do
that
and this is just not what we think
respectable people should do
uh so we can deny your individual right
to pursue this kind of activity i'm sure
you would agree that we should not
uh not make an argument because we're
afraid of what conservatives will
appropriate from the way we're talking
that seems like again a negative sort of
freedom to me it's not a positive
argument i think this actually has very
negative connotations they're not gonna
be listening to this anyway but matt
you're not born privately
you're born into a language a society
mores
this is not just a this is not like
you're going to be conservative you
appeal to it yeah
it's not just a group yeah cultural
values you
you're born into a physical environment
you're born up north versus in a hot
place you're going to be a different
person right
i completely agree with that but the
problem is the kind of way that you cash
this out
right uh there are ways that you can
cash this out that are a lot more
emancipatory than others right
you can cash this out as an argument for
in a marxist sense that
we are not private atomized individuals
uh
we live with others so our emancipation
depends upon the emancipation of all
right that's one way you can cash those
out i think that's the right way to cash
it out
that's the only one that eric has
appealed to
so far i don't know i'm not criticizing
eric directly i'm saying that
you need to be careful who else is
having a debate here
from each according to their ability and
so on but what i'm saying is this other
kind of argument
associated with the kind of rhetoric he
gave which is that you know society
pre-exists the individual
can be operationalized for very
different purposes and one of the
reasons i bring this up is
i think that we need to be very cautious
about invoking it precisely because it
can be mobilized and has been mobilized
by generations of conservatives
uh for far less than emancipatory
purposes i feel like i can clear up the
confusion that's going on here because i
think there's
i think there's a bit of a talking past
each other and like i think the problem
is and i noticed it much earlier
that like it seemed like eric was making
a point that all of us agree with which
is like a
philosophically anthropological point
about like how the human being is
developed which is like in the context
of
other people and like language and
community and like that that is prior
that is like philosophically prior
but really what matt is talking about is
what are we going to morally prioritize
so it's not a point
about like what is the anthropological
basis of the human animal of the human
being of human subjectivity
it's a point about what are we going to
morally prioritize and i agree with that
if you morally prioritize the group that
opens the door to a lot of cons that is
very consistent with conservative groups
and like
i don't think that eric was even saying
that he's morally prioritizing i
i heard eric is saying liberalism which
i disagree with him on this
is based on this philosophical
anthropology of just like the individual
is some isolated thing like no
self-respecting liberal theorist thinks
that anymore since like locke
and and like of course the
anthropological point as i said we all
agree with the human beings
are our innocence so that is how i see
this confusion uh all right i'm losing
my objectivity because i'm becoming
invested in the argument
but can we extend i i just want to say i
agree with eric okay
i wasn't attacking eric as being a
closet conservative or something well
then you're shadow boxing people who
aren't even existing in this
conversation hey don't worry about
hurting my feelings man
the reason that i'm bringing this up is
just because
i want people to be cognizant of how
this rhetoric can as viktor said it be
morally mobilized
uh to unm like a non-emancipatory
purposes and has been mobilized many
times before
right well because you you morally value
the essence of some group of some
collective which was kind of my earlier
point about like how do you draw the
lines around what collected but i don't
even think eric was defending
the moral prioritization of the group um
unless i don't know you could correct me
if i'm wrong eric but like that's i
wasn't hearing you as actually you were
making more of a philosophical
anthropological point
well i mean there's all these extremes
we have to avoid and i think hegel
brings them all up you know the tyranny
of the individual
autocratic rulership the tyranny of the
masses more like what happened in
stalin's russia
i mean there's all these extremes we
have to if you prioritize the group
before the individual then you've got
the tyranny of the masses
if you privilege the individual before
the group
which i argue that many in the classical
liberal tradition but yes i agree
not so much anymore they did do that
they did
think because how else could you argue
that you're a rational
individual in a marketplace with
self-interest
if you also admit the point that your
self-interest is actually like
constructed by your time in this world
and your
the process of incorporating other
people's values into your own worldview
you couldn't really make that argument
you have to say well no you're an atomic
individual with rational capabilities
able to
put aside moral arguments based on
feeling and able to just make moral
arguments based on reason
and choose the valuable option
what's best for you philadelphia right
reason will prevail
pickles will prevail
we've both gotten our chances to say our
points on
this issue which i think is the third
point
and we can transition into the fourth
point i wanted to bring it up because i
was interested
i'm genuinely interested in your point
of view on this
and you can bring up the previous
discussion because this is more
a more a general point um i wanted to
recall
diogenes because diogenes thought that
human social life
was inferior to a dog's life because
they're
they're both miserable but the uh
human life is just steeped in hypocrisy
so so he decided to sit in the market
and
jack himself off live in a barrel but my
question yeah jack offered a barrel in
the middle of the market
so we have this system we have this
system
based on a lot of florid language
um and i want to address the issue i
think it was eric's fourth point from
the very beginning
that it's anti-realist it uses a lot of
floored language
we've been saying freedom and mutual
respect
often over and over again liberation so
on so
what happens to those points of view
that disagree with this
that don't want to participate how do
you get self or mutual
respect among among your uh governed
electorate
without coercing mutual respect once how
do you maintain neutrality towards the
good
yeah where does state kick in
in terms of establishing this system not
in something that
you all want to believe is true or you
want to interpret as true but how do you
get to
dealing with the way that this functions
when people don't want to
listen to it well i mean so i would say
that
it's it's it kind of this is kind of
speaking to like the puzzle i mentioned
like at the beginning
that that there's you know people if
people don't want to
feel this kind of mutual respect um
i mean i think you do have to prioritize
uh like
like rights for individuals and if
people don't like that i guess
like you know they can go and try to
start a commune or something
like that but that's going to be
permissible in
in in a context in a liberal context
there's nothing that's stopping that
from being permissible
but i guess i don't know like so is your
is your question basically like what do
you do with people who don't want to who
don't want to be liberals who don't want
to respect others
like crime like how do you deal with
crime how does a liberal
who who believes in this whole system of
oh this is the
the best that we can do then deal with
those who don't want to do it the
discontent
as freud would say so first of all i
don't i don't think that we've done
anywhere close to the best that we can
do i do not think that
any any point in which like liberalism
has reached its you know optimal
oh i'm not saying that over time i mean
even in your in your philosophical
giving the benefit of the doubt yeah
okay so in my mind so so i do think that
i do think that these discontents a lot
of these discontents i think can be
rooted in there is social science
research and there is
you know some political science research
showing that you know having
economic freedom and like having some
some like material conditions being
taken care of
will go a long way i do think that a lot
of these kind of like like
movements of resentment um are often
going to be
related to people who who are somehow
economically disenfranchised
not always but sometimes but i do agree
with some critics of liberalism on both
the left and the right that there is
like a little bit of a problem which was
the puzzle that i was getting to at the
beginning that
you know ultimately because of
liberalism's emphasis on
you know formal rights and uh you know
uh in like to some extent like nominal
like prior morally prioritizing the
individual
um yeah like like there's there's a
trade-off right like i think that
there's ultimately a trade-off between
having uh like the moral priority of the
individual but also like
those like there must have been
something nice right like living in a
in some like feudalistic society where
you feel like you know what your place
is and there is some
majesty from above that is like that you
are a cog in a machine and you know what
your role is you know what your meaning
is
in it i mean that's like an extreme
example but i do think that there is
something
uh that is lost when you when and like
something kind of disorienting about
being in a world where you actually have
to kind of decide for yourself
um but ultimately like you can't
reconcile those two things i don't think
that you can reconcile some need for
feeling like some meaning from above is
given to you and you don't have to feel
disoriented in a liberal society um
i would rather feel disoriented and and
be in a liberal society than have then
have like some
arbitrary rule from above but i think
that especially conservative critics
you know when i was i have this book
here in front of me why liberalism
failed from patrick dineen
uh i thought that was where i was
getting yeah right right when critiques
like that this is something that people
worry about and i don't know
i don't have an answer for that but just
i guess i would just say like let's take
care of the economic
material conditions make sure everybody
can have as much freedom as they can
with basic
incomes and whatever kind of
institutional support
and hopefully that'll that'll give
people time to feel more effectively
connected to other people because
ultimately we do need
other like some form of community and i
think part of it is
like you know shitty material conditions
that don't allow that to flourish
properly but yeah there's always going
to be some people
who are who malign and miss that feeling
where there is some
overarching rule that is telling you
what to live and like i'm sorry for
those people but like
tough no it's not tough you have to
coerce them then
that's the if you're gonna have a
liberal state then there must be
coercion and power
no no no no there doesn't have to be
coercion because they can start their
commune and they can all go and worship
whatever they want
well there it is yeah i want to say i
think that there's
three things i want to point out here
that i can see eric was jumping on so
i'll try to keep it really quick
okay uh first off i think that there
when it comes to
groups that hold fundamentally illiberal
views sometimes put
we should tolerate them to the absolute
utmost end possible
but in instances where they become
violent or militant
then yeah there are going to have to be
instances where the liberal state's
going to step in
uh to try to at least quell the kind of
radical edge
uh to what they're doing and i think
this is true of fascist groups for
example
and i see that they say that this is a
kind of compromise that liberal theory
makes with reality
and i don't think there's really any a
priori way to answer
when it should do this i think that in a
lot of circumstances it has to be
determined
empirically historically right and you
can see this with a lot of the
jurisprudence and debates about that go
on through the liberal tradition where
people ask things like
can we tolerate neo-nazis can we
tolerate the clan uh can we tolerate
uh you know uh like radical uh
right-wing terrorists
you know uh and we try our best and
sometimes
we just realize we can't anymore okay
yeah i just went to
sorry you can finish your next two
points i just want to put the uh
point down i think we're all talking
about the same thing but if you're gonna
base
a political theory on individual rights
then how do you reconcile that with
power and the exercise of power so
anyway sorry next point
and i think that there are circumstances
where we just have to do this right
on the second point i agree 100 with
victor uh that
a lot of the kind of alienation and
hyper partisanship that emerges right
now
uh is a consequence of unequal
stratified hyper-competitive neoliberal
material conditions
right uh so if we were to achieve
something like a liberal socialist
society
uh where resources were distributed in a
much more egalitarian manner where
workers were able to actually have some
say
uh over how their companies are directed
uh so on and so forth would be a lot
better and
victor said it really nicely so i don't
really want to elaborate on this too
much the one point that i'll add
is that i think one of the reasons why
people feel a profound sense of
alienation that's connected
to neoliberal material conditions is
that they rightly assume that economic
elites wield a lot more power than they
do
and that the kind of representative
democracy we live in is really just
formalistic and kind of a sham
right and i think this goes to show you
why we need a renewal of democratic life
not just to legitimate political
institutions but also so that people can
create a deeper sense
of voluntary community with others which
kind of speaks to the communitarian
ethos that some
conservatives raise without the coercive
mechanisms
that are associated with that and i
think we can spread this idea of
democracy to a lot of areas of life you
know whether we talk about the workplace
the family gender relations whatever on
the last point about realism
uh i like to say actually that one of
the things that's great about
liberalism and it's precisely that it's
a nominalistic philosophy
predicated on this by the scientific
method uh that says we can't know
reality in and of itself
okay uh and there are a lot of reasons
for this and we can have a law
philosophical discussion about it uh but
the reason is that and this kind of
speaks to
what victor was saying as well about
this longing for meaning uh one of the
things that's characteristic
of many streams of reactionary thought
is they all claim to be realists right
everything in the universe has its place
it simply is what it is because it has
essential qualities to it
uh and because everything in the
universe has its place
uh everything should stay there right uh
and this
extends all the way down to the social
hierarchies we see in
humankind right and my argument
is that we should take adorno seriously
and reject the tyranny of positivism
and say actually what we don't want is
reality uh in this conservative sense of
realism
uh what we want is to change reality and
make it better
right and that's what i see as being at
the epicenter of the liberal project
at its best and i stress at its best
since as eric said
uh there's tons of warts that you can
find in the tradition
including plenty that i think a dump on
pretty regularly yeah
yeah well i had i had a response i'll
i'll respond to both of you actually
um i'll just i'll just lead in by saying
what victor was saying
actually put me in mind when when you
were talking about the sort of
feudalistic world view versus i don't
know what the the post
french revolutionary sort of world are
hungry for that for what i was talking
about i think
to someone what you were saying actually
put me in mind of of cavell's version of
skepticism saying that like
no like skepticism any long isn't any
longer about
you know despair over the fact that we
can never be certain about anything now
skepticism has to be about
coming to terms with living in an
ungrounded world that's
skepticism for cavell and i think you
expressed that very beautifully
um or at least what you said put me in
mind of that
um i think the problem
with saying within a liberal society
however we can just allow people to go
off and form commune communes and
break off and stuff i think that would
present a problem to certain liberal
perspectives for instance i would bring
up what like what is
when rawls is struggling with the idea
of positive freedom
you know in the wake of isaiah berlin's
essay two concepts of freedom there's a
negative and a positive isaiah
ultimately comes down on the side of the
negative freedom
but i think rawls thinks about this a
little more and he makes a distinction
between
civic humanism and civic republicanism
and he says civic humanism is wrong
because that permits people to go off
and seal themselves up in a private
sphere
but he comes down on the side of civic
republicanism
we need to encourage people to become
educated and participate in politics
become active political actors that's
what
so rawls would have a big problem with
that the
the sort of liberal liberalism that you
were
maybe just hinted at with the idea that
like if you're not happy with it go off
and form a commune it's like well rawls
would say
no actually get educated and go into
politics and change it
you can't we can't live in liberal
societies and have a long
democracy if we're just also allowing
people to seal themselves up in some
sphere
away from everyone else depends on what
the nature of the sphere like but i
agree i mean
i was vague in what i meant but i do
think that roles would find it
permissible to have free associations
with whatever you want they would just
have to be reasonable
and they would have to remain
non-violent
unless you disagree with them the most
militant i've ever seen you victor
like you actually got kind of [ __ ]
angry there you were like you know they
can go join a [ __ ] comment and if not
tough
do you agree though like don't you think
that roles would allow some communes
this is also the most political i've
seen eric so i think this just brings
out the worst in all of us
i like this this god just as spicy as
you as you were dreaming of pills
yeah i thought this went really well if
anything the weird thing is i think eric
displayed the most liberal virtues
personally out of all of us
i have to say that i think i agree you
just take anything you like and then
call it liberal
i'm more liberal than the liberals man
he's the more radical
i i am engaging in the self-critique
eric you didn't finish your life go
ahead eric eric finish
my my last point was really just to what
matt was saying about
um you know the idea that the state can
come
in and you know make things
run a little more smoothly by by
ensuring that people's
i don't know if this is the way you put
it it was a little while ago now but
like
the state is allowed to come in and make
regulations
and make sure that people's individual
freedom is not being trampled on
and that sort of thing and i i agree
with that
to the extent that yeah of course
liberalism is always about compromise
and if you can
if you can live in a liberal state and
socialists want one thing and
neoconservatives want another thing and
you can give it both to them and that's
what they'll do
but the problem with liberalism is when
it comes to those decision points that i
was talking about earlier
when the decision you can only
prioritize the individual or the group
you can only prioritize the free market
or
state regulation when those decisions
come around and i'm going to give
another example and it has to do with
climate
change again is when the way uh stop
[ __ ] sucking the planet
climate change is being dealt with in
terms of the liberal
status quo when you go to things like un
cop
conferences they are talking about how
to financialize nature
and make it visible to economic
calculation right and they
come down on the side of the free market
they will never
like okay the if the compromise is there
they're gonna find it and they're gonna
make it because liberals are all about
compromise
but if the compromise cannot happen if a
decision
needs to be made then they will come
down on the side of the free market and
say okay well we can't
like look at how kovid rolled out
originally of course we had a more
right-wing
conservative kind of liberalism and
power at the time but the point there
was that
we cannot stop the market forces we
can't
just stop the economy because everything
will collapse sacrifice the people to
the economy because it's our
god right speaking of higher things
coming down below the economy is like a
religion
in liberalism and of course not so much
in the more progressive strands but this
is gg's point all the time right
capitalism
he quotes benjamin capitalism is like a
religion
anyway that's besides the point and now
you're shadow boxing so i have to call
you out too
if you have to come to one of those
decisions you have to prioritize
something either the group or the
individual
the state of the market the economy or
the environment
you know the the way that the status quo
works right now is they will always come
down on the side of the individual
the market and the economy possibly to
the detriment
of the group to the state to the
environment
and that's what that's just what happens
okay so your compromises are awesome
but when you can't compromise what the
liberal lore tells us is going to be
what
decides the ultimate outcome and too
many
of course if there were more good
liberals like you maybe in positions of
power
then maybe this wouldn't happen but as
it does happen you know
we go for the market
we go for the individual we go for the
economy [ __ ] the environment [ __ ] the
state and [ __ ] the group right and
that's just how
things unroll and we should change that
and like i said good liberals like you
maybe
disagree with that and i hope you do
smash rhetoric and this is why i say we
need to smash neoliberalism
right yeah those are all problems
yeah these are all problems of the
currently existing liberal democratic
set up that we have right now which i
think matt did a good job of explaining
like enhancing you know more democracy
in the workplace like re reinvigorating
our democratic institutions which
like matt mentioned that's actually the
topic of the book of the of the article
i'm writing for his edited volume right
like that like just i mean
i'm arguing for completely getting rid
of electoral politics as they exist
but just by way of reference eric is
also contributing to this volume as well
it's kind of a group project oh yeah
that's true that's true yeah you have
you have one which i think is
is related to the environmental topic
but but in any case it's just the point
is like
um i think that you can be a liberal uh
like that those those critiques you have
are the same critiques that i have um
but i just still think that
what what i believe in morally and
politically is still part of the liberal
project where maybe
maybe what you do you don't consider it
to be part of the liberal project i
don't know
i mean i guess i'll play devil's
advocate and say that's just still
liberalism
whatever flavor you choose i don't like
liberalism because i don't want to
choose a flavor of oppression
okay well guys i think i think this was
certainly going to be fun for everybody
else i feel kind of stressed out i don't
like the
i don't like the conflict you wanted the
con that's what you wanted you [ __ ]
said it yeah
you were like you're too polite i didn't
want it for myself i wanted it for the
listeners i am a martyr
i'm a martyr we're handing out red pills
they're handing out blue pills
by the way this is our 30th episode
christ began his ministry at
30 so we have at least three left
but he was dead by 33 wasn't he happy
i i would i would just i have like a
concluding like remark
for which i i kind of think to me my
observation is that
and you know as so much more often than
i would like it to be the case
in like sort of academic discourse with
you know sit with a bunch of academics
sitting around arguing about something
is like i ultimately think that most of
us agree about almost every single
concrete issue like we probably are very
close on most issues
and really like the biggest disagreement
was like i want to call this thing that
we all agree with liberalism and you're
like i want to say that those things
aren't really part of liberalism like to
me it just seemed like there were a lot
of things that it's an argument more
about like
what counts as liberalism what's
intrinsic to liberalism
but like when we brought up examples of
like what specific things we don't like
or criticize or what specific things we
do like
it seemed like we pretty much all agreed
i think we fundamentally disagree about
the constitution of the individual
and it's along uh those polar axes and i
think we still disagree i don't think so
i think i agree on the anthropology of
it it was it was the the disagreement
was really about like where the moral
uh where the moral in like um
justification for things is located
um yeah but like i mean i think my point
was also
that i mean i'm playing devil's advocate
but i also believe it a little bit is
that you can't
say these things aren't liberalism you
can't say
that the chicago school of economics led
by milton freeman is not a liberal
institution that is producing liberal
subjects
of course i don't believe if you go into
a society that has
liberal democratic institutions that
every person you're going to run into is
going to be a liberal subject
i don't have that sort of broad scope
view of liberalism
but i do think that if you want to be a
liberal
and you want to say that you're a
liberal you should own
the fact that liberalism has also
produced some pretty
shitty ideas and if i want to be a
communist
i have to do the same thing i have to
say well
communism has been pretty [ __ ] up in
its actual manifestations in history but
i'm going to own that i'm not going to
say ah stalin wasn't really economy
right you're right you're right and i
didn't i didn't mean i didn't mean to
sound like like
like i was saying uh you know really i
think what i mean is
the argument was not so much like oh
this isn't liberalism but like what's
intrinsic to the to like what i say is
the moral core of liberalism and like
yeah it's been instantiated in a bunch
of ways but i still think
and actually interestingly when you were
talking there like it made me think that
there may be is like also a divide on
like where we think about these things
philosophically like between matt and i
versus like you you two is
i think that you two have more of a
tendency from at least based on my
observation
that um to to start with like a more
like philosophical like ontological
metaphysical question about like where
the human being
like how do we understand the human
being it's relation to reality which
i think both matt and i are interested
in too but i think we have a tendency to
slip into
right away not that question which i
think we agree with you on but
what is where do you f like locate the
moral justification
for things like we're starting i think
we look at things from a more moral
philosophy perspective than you guys do
which i think maybe led to some of our
decisions well we never got to the hume
guillotine which is there is no ought
from is
and i think eric and i both say oh
you're talking about odd questions
bye yeah exactly we have to do a whole
episode on moral motivations for people
and what what the basis for moral
assertions
to end our episode on libs it is going
to be king of the libs
making half a point because his points
are so long matt mcmanus
take us home yeah no i just want to say
i think that's actually a really
interesting question
because fundamentally i think the person
who raised the best objection to
liberalism
uh was actually nietzsche right um and
one of the reasons is because nietzsche
really pushes the question to exactly
the point
that victor was talking about and pills
was referencing which is
you have this axiomatic assumption that
we're all moral equals that people
should be free
uh that human life is worth a damn why
should we pursue many of that why should
i grant you that
uh all this is just a vulgarized
iteration of the judeo-christian
tradition that we better off rejecting
and you know all the stuff that comes
from that and i think it's a really good
objection
right i mean and i don't know a lot of
liberal thinkers who actually have a
very sustained answer to it
uh in part because meta ethics is
difficult and also because i think most
of us
rely on kind of axiomatic reasoning when
it comes to a lot of our moral values
right in fact i'm not really sure we
could do away with it right um
but i mean i think there are a lot of
objections you can make this that are
really strong hopefully we can get to
explore them in the future
good point i'd also like to plug that
pills and i
are doing a series on semiotics and
there's going to be some
parallels to what we were talking about
today that you might not expect it
for instance the way that we construct
the individual and invest them with
rights
and then try to extend those rights to
non-human beings i find that to be
completely analogical to the way
that people construct a vision of
meaning based on linguistics and
language and then try to extend
that to non-humans and i think it's a i
think it's an error to do it
in that way so check out our semiotics
series for that
and as you heard a few references too uh
everyone in here but me apparently is uh
coming out with a book
anyway guys uh we've gone long but i
think it was a great discussion good
episode
some conflict some stress my heart rate
went up
i hope you guys enjoyed it listeners i
hope you i hope you got off on on the
spicy disagreements
yeah so what makes us such effective
podcasters though is our
our chemistry and our i hope so the
electricity that flows between
our veiled hatred for each other but
right below the surface
[ __ ] libs okay matt stopped recording
but he says uh
it went really well so just for the
listeners
all right i'll see you again the end is
nigh you'll hear from us later for
episode 31 uh thank you all for
listening
so uh bye victor thank you listeners bye
bye eric oh eric stopped his recording
too
so bye from eric and matt this is pills
talk to you later